>> WHY IS THE WHITE HOUSE
TRUSTING THE TALIBAN?
STARTLING NEW REPORTS COMING IN
ABOUT THE TERROR GROUP CARRYING
OUT MASS KILLINGS GOING HOUSE TO
HOUSE, EXECUTING AMERICAN ALLIES
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN LEFT
BEHIND.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS THAT THEY
CAN'T CONFIRM THE REPORTS, BUT
IT'S STILL KEEPING THE DOOR OPEN
FOR COOPERATION WITH THE GROUP
TO GET STRANDED AMERICANS AND
AFGHAN ALLIES OUT OF THE
COUNTRY.
>> NO ONE IS SAYING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, NO ONE, THE
PRESIDENT, SECRETARY OF DEFENSE,
NOTHING FROM THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY THAT THE TALIBAN ARE
GOOD ACTORS.
RIGHT?
WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT.
WE WILL JUDGE AND WE WANT TO
MAKE VERY CLEAR THAT WE'LL JUDGE
THE TALIBAN BY THEIR ACTIONS AND
STAY IN CLOSE COORDINATION WITH
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY ON
THE STEPS MOVING FORWARD.
>> JOEY, WHAT IS DISTURBING
ABOUT THIS NONE OF THIS IS A
SURPRISE.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
AND ACCORDING TO THEM, WHAT THEY
DID, THEY BACKED THEMSELVES IN
TO A CORNER.
THEY HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO MAY
NICE WITH THE TALIBAN.
THEY HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO ASK
FOR THEIR HELP.
WE HAD A CHANCE TO SECURE THE
CITY?
BRING IN 10,000 TROOPS.
YOU'RE THE PRESIDENT.
YOU HAVE 3 1/2 MORE YEARS TO END
THIS WAR.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO HAND IT OFF
TO THE NEXT PERSON, END IT
CORRECTLY AND USE YOUR TERM TO
DO IT.
IF YOU WANT TO GIVE UP POLITICAL
COLLATERAL, DO IT SAVING
AMERICAN LIVES AND NOT HOLDING A
CAMPAIGN PROMISE THAT WASN'T
YOURS TO BEGIN WITH YOU.
IT WAS THE GUY BEFORE YOU.
HE SET IT IN MOTION AND YOU
DON'T FOLLOW HIS PLAN.
WE CAN'T TRUST THE TALIBAN.
HERE'S WHY.
MOST OF THEIR YOUNG FIGHTERS ARE
COMING FROM PAKISTAN.
THEY HAVE A BLOOD THIRST LIKE
NOBODY ELSE.
THEY HAVEN'T SEEN WAR.
THE WAR MIGHT NOT HAVE TOUCHED
THEIR LIVES, THIS IS AN IDEALISM
OF RADICAL ISLAM IN THEIR HEAD.
THE TALIBAN DOESN'T HAVE A
CHOICE TO BE THIS RULING CLASS
BECAUSE THEY'LL LOSE WHAT MAKES
THEM POWERFUL, THE BLOOD THIRSTY
YOUNG MEN THAT THINK THAT THEY
HAVE TO EXECUTE PEOPLE IN FULL
TO FULFILL THEIR GOAL, THIS IS
NEVER A TALIBAN 2.0 AND THAT'S
WHY.
THEY TALK TO US LIKE WELL, WE'LL
SEE IF WE GIVE THEM FOREIGN AID.
THAT LOOKS LIKE A GUIDED BOMB ON
THEIR FOREHEAD.
THAT'S THE THREAT.
NOT WILL WE PAY YOU, WILL WE
KILL YOU.
IF THEY TELL YOU IT'S OVER THE
HORIZON, WE'LL DO THAT, TOO.
>> THERE WAS A HEADLINE THAT
CAME OUT A COUPLE WEEKS AGAINST.
THE TALIBAN TELL AFGHAN WOMEN TO
STAY HOME BECAUSE THE SOLDIERS
ARE NOT TRAINED TO RESPECT THEM.
THAT IS WHAT THE THE HEADLINE
SAID.
>> THERE'S LIMITED GENTS LEFT
BEHIND IN AFGHANISTAN.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS LAST NIGHT
HAHN KENNEDY.
HOW GOOD EVERYONE HAS GOTTEN AT
TROLLING, RIGHT?
THESE TERROR GROUPS ARE
FANTASTIC AT IT.
ANOTHER STATEMENT THE TALIBAN
PUT OUT ABOUT HOW A WONDERFUL
PARTNER CHINA IS.
NOTHING IS GOING TO UPSET
ANYTHING MORE THAT YOU'RE GONE
AND I'M TURNING TOPY BEST
FRIEND, PRESIDENT XI OVER HERE.
WHO KNOWS AT THIS POINT IF ANY
MONEY IS COMING IN AND OUT OF
THE COUNTRY.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT THE
WORLD BANK CAN LOOK OVER.
WE DO HAVE TO WORK WITH PEOPLE
THAT WE DON'T LIKE ALL THE TIME.
THAT'S A WHOLE RANGE OF EVEN
WESTERN DEMOCRACIES WHERE WE
DISAGREE WITH PEOPLE DOWN TO
TERROR ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
RUNNING A NUMBER OF COUNTRIES,
THIS ONE PARTICULARLY HURTS
BECAUSE OF OUR INVESTMENT IN
THIS COUNTRY FOR 20 YEARS.
THE SPEED AT WHICH THEY TOOK
OVER.
WE WATCHED A LOT OF THE FOOTAGE
ABOUT THE 11 DAYS.
THAT DOES STICK OUT AS SOMETHING
THAT DIDN'T EVEN SEE PRESIDENT
GHANI KNEW IT WOULD HAPPEN
FASTER THAN THE U.S.
11 DAYS IS AN ASTONISHINGLY
QUICK TAKEOVER.
>> I WAS GOING TO GO TO SEAN.
IT PARTICULARLY HURTS AND I'M
SPEAKING FOR JOEY HAVING
LISTENED TO HIM VERY CAREFULLY,
THE LANGUAGE NOT ONLY PUTTING
THE HAQQANI NETWORK IN CHARGE OF
SECURITY IN KABUL, AGAIN, OF AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS WANTED HERE,
THE HEAD OF THE HAQQANI NETWORK
WANTED HERE IN THE FBI FOR BEING
INVOLVED IN THE KILLING
INCLUDING AN AMERICAN.
THERE'S A BOUNTY FOR HIM.
$5 MILLION BOUNTY WITH THE
LANGUAGE USED BY GENERAL
McKENZIE OF CENTCOM REFERRING TO
THE TALIBAN AS HELPFUL AND
PRAGMATIC AND BUSINESS-LIKE.
WHAT HURTS THE MOST, SEAN, IS
THE FACT THAT WE DO HAVE TO RELY
ON THIS VICIOUS TERROR
ORGANIZATION BECAUSE JOE BIDEN
LEFT AFGHAN ALLIES, PARTNERS AND
EVEN AMERICANS BEHIND.
>> TO JESSICA'S POINTS, WE HAVE
TO WORK WITH PEOPLE WE DON'T
LIKE BUT WE DIDN'T HAVE TO WORK
WITH THE TALIBAN LIKE THIS.
IT WAS JOE BIDEN'S DECISION THAT
PUT US IN THIS SITUATION.
DOES THE WHITE HOUSE THINK WE'RE
DUMB AND DON'T HAVE VIDEOTAPES
OR YOUTUBE TO LOOK AT WHAT THEY
SAID BEFORE?
THE WHITE HOUSE IS SAYING THE
TALIBAN ARE OUR PARTNERS.
NOW THEY'RE SAYING THEY'RE NOT
GOOD PEOPLE.
WHO IS MANNING THE GATE TO GET
IN TO THE KABUL AIRPORT WHEN THE
13 MEN AND WOMEN DIED?
IT WAS THE TALIBAN.
SO THEY WERE TRUSTING THE
TALIBAN.
NOW THEY'RE SAYING THEY'RE NOD
GOOD ACTORS?
WHO DO YOU THINK FOR 20 YEARS
WAS ATTACKING GUYS LIKE JOEY
JONES?
>> THEY CHANGED THEIR TONE
BECAUSE THEY KNEW IT.
NOW THEY HAVE ENDED THEIR
OPERATION.
>> THE THING IS THEY THINK WE'RE
STUPID.
SAY ONE THING ONE WEEK AND
SOMETHING THE OTHER WEEK AND
THINK WE'LL FORGET.
NO, LET'S ROLL THE TAPE AND GO
HOW CAN YOU HAVE CHANGING
STORIES WHEN THE TALIBAN HASN'T
CHANGED MORE THAN 20 YEARS?
I AGREE.
WE SHOULD BE DROPPING BOMBS.
>> ANDY McCARTHY PROSECUTED IN
IN THE TERRORISTS IN THE FIRST
BOMBING.
HE TOLD ME THE TALIBAN HAS NEVER
BEEN ANYTHING BUT THE TALIBAN.
HE DESCRIBED THE NATION STATE,
THE EMIRATE THAT THEY SET UP AND
HOW IT'S DIFFERENT THAN ANYTHING
THAT LOOKS LIKE A REPRESENTATIVE
GOVERNMENT.
>> GENERAL MILLEY SAID THAT THEY
ARE RUTHLESS.
WHETHER THEY CHANGE REMAINS TO
BE SCENE.
WE HAVE A FEW SKEPTICS HERE
AMONG US TODAY --
>> THE LINE THERE, WHETHER THEY
CHANGE REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
DID NORTH KOREA OTTO WARMBIER
WAS A SPY?
NO.
THAT'S THE BEST VERSION OF THE
TALIBAN YOU'LL GET.
THAT'S FINE.
YOU DON'T NEED TO CHANGE THIS
FOR MY FEELINGS.
YOU NEED TO DO IT SO MY
12-YEAR-OLD SON DOESN'T FIGHT
WHEN HE'S 18.
THAT'S WHY I CARE.
>> YOU HAVE COUNTRIES LIKE
DENMARK IS THE FIRST TO SAY WE
WILL NOT RECOGNIZE THIS AS A
LEGIT IT IN GOVERNMENT, THE
TALIBAN.
WE HAVE TO SEE -- CHINA WILL
COZY UP, RUSSIA.
WHAT GETS ME IS WATCHING THEM,
GOING AROUND EXECUTING PEOPLE,
SLAUGHTERING PEOPLE, KILLING
PEOPLE LIKE A FOLK MUSICIAN
BECAUSE THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN
MUSIC.
THEY HAVE PEOPLE HERE SAYING
WOMEN HAVE IT WORSE IN THE STATE
OF TEXAS THAN THEY DO UNDER THE
TALIBAN IN AFGHANISTAN.
IT'S AN OUTRAGEOUS STATEMENT.
IF YOU THINK THAT, I'M SURE
THERE'S ARE PEOPLE THAT WOULD
BUY YOU A PLANE TICKET TO HANG
OUT WITH THE TALIBAN AND SEE HOW
YOU REALLY FEEL ABOUT THAT.
>> I DON'T HAVE WORDS TO
DESCRIBE A STATEMENT LIKE THAT.
>> CRAZY.
>> AS YOU KNOW, M